well this is the fascination watch which
we're launching this year in Basel it's
absolutely extraordinary one in the
world so there's a hundred and fifty
carats of diamonds the biggest one being
just under forty carats and that stone
is d cutter and flawless one of nature's
true rare gems and this is probably the
most valuable watch stroke bracelet in
the world today it's about 40 million US
dollars a piece like this every single
diamond is jointed it's all moving in in
every single direction
it's absolutely three-dimensional so
it's it's an engineering job and that
needs to be planned out very carefully
and that makes it supremely comfortable
and flexible on the wrist I think this
will more than likely end up in Asia
they have a tremendous desire of
fabulous unique things they have a
cultural affinity to diamonds and they
love owning and collecting fabulous
jewelry and this is probably one of the
most important pieces in the world
available today it will generate a huge
amount of interest so they will